all right so you're like wow i can't
believe we had that entire discussion
over a single mark well it's because uh
there was a lot hiding within it so that
was believe it or not question one uh
let's go a little further and see what
was the next question i picked out
okay it's all the way into extended
response let's have a look at question
11. it says
part a
sketch the region of the argan plane in
which z plus two
z bar plus two is less than four showing
all relevant detail okay so
what do we do with this question well i
really like this question because it it
pulls out let's get a new page over here
it pulls out or rather it combines our
understanding of complex numbers as
algebraic objects and simultaneously as
geometric objects right it's like hey
we're going to ask you to do some
algebraic manipulation on this but what
you're going to get out of this is an
interpretation of that algebraic result
that's a picture on the argan diagram
okay
so we'll start just by stating the
particular inequality that they want us
to graph um what subset of the complex
plane will satisfy this particular
inequality
now because what i want to get towards
is this sort of a cartesian
representation right eventually i'm
going to head towards um some kind of
inequality which has x's and y's right
so
i will make some substitution of like
let z equal x plus iy and then the
general x and general y will exist on
this on the argon diagram however before
i do that i want to see if there's any
kind of manipulation i can do in the zs
right in the complex form before i split
everything out into real and imaginary
that might make things simpler for me
especially because i notice these
conjugates right and conjugates are
there because they have very useful
properties in how they cancel out with
each other okay so let's have a go what
i'm going to do is i'm just going to
expand what i what i have here and see
what emerges so i'm going to have just
doing you know first outside inside last
z z-bar
i'm going to get 2 lots of z i'm going
to get 2 lots of z bar and then
2 times 2 gives me 4
and then i'll move that over a little
bit so that i can have my less than 4
over on the right hand side
okay now this is really great because
the particular um expansion or algebraic
terms the um this polynomial right sort
of thing that you're going to get here
the binomials that are going to combine
here they pair up the conjugates very
nicely that are going to give you
results that maybe you instantly
recognize right
z zed bar i know what that is but i'll
just write that out the front
momentarily
and double of z plus z bar
i also know what that is because the
whole idea of the conjugate is that the
imaginary parts are positive and
negative if you add them they cancel
okay
while i'm at it i notice there's a 4 on
both sides so i'm just going to subtract
that from both sides okay
so at this point i think it's
appropriate to now say okay i've done
enough simplifying i've noticed that the
combination of z and n bar z and its
conjugate will allow me to simplify some
things here but just to make it really
clear for us let me just put this bit of
work in here to make the substitution
really clear right
for starters if oops daisy is z equals x
plus i y this is the substitution i was
mentioning then for instance z plus z
bar
we just said the imaginary parts would
cancel so that would just leave you with
double the real part so i'm just going
to get 2 x right
and while i'm at it z times z bar maybe
you don't just get this one like
straight away
that multiplication is going to be x
plus i y
x minus i y right this is kind of a
difference of squares situation except
the fact that i've got these eyes
hanging out there so they're going to
make my difference of squares into a sum
of squares because the i squared will
become negative 1. so what i'm going to
do is i'm just going to flag these two
objects here
and i'm going to substitute them into
let's just name this let's call this
inequality 1 and i'm going to substitute
these two results in terms of x's and
y's
into
inequality 1. right here we go
so the zz bars hanging out the front so
i'll write that as x squared plus y
squared i'll just put the colors in to
make it really clear for you and then
i'm doubling what am i doubling and the
answer is 2x that's what i get when i
add my complex number with its conjugate
and that let's just make that bracket
theta is less than 0. okay
now i can see at this point i've got the
x squared and this is a 4x and you know
you can clearly see with the x squared
and the y squared
being that they're added together this
is going to be a circle right or some
subset of circles because i've got an
inequality so where my brain is going is
i'm going to need to complete the square
if i've got x squared plus 4x here then
i'm going to halve and square this
coefficient and thankfully this has
already been hard for me look it's 2
times 2. it's almost like the question
was designed to make this easy so
therefore i'm going to have the x
squared
plus the 4x
to complete the square i will add half
that squared gives me 4.
funnily enough i subtracted that before
so i might as well add it back to both
sides and then you just got that y
squared hanging out there so far so good
i'll just factorize it to make it a
little more geometrically obvious what
shape i'm dealing with
okay so
the boundary of this
argan diagram this subset of complex
plane is going to be the circle
x plus 2 or squared plus y squared
equals 4. that's how you get the
boundary line of
a subset of the complex plane and then
because i see this less than i want all
of the circles that have that radius of
4 but smaller right i'm not including
actually 4 because the boundary is not
included okay
all right so let's draw this thing up
i'm going to take some
some nice big fat lines here so i think
by the way
i'm going to get a radius of 2 and i've
shifted horizontally 2 units to the left
so therefore i'm not even going to
bother really drawing the positive side
let's draw this so here comes the
imaginary axis i'll put some um
put something on some arrows on that
surely here's one
three
four so this is imaginary
this is real and i'll admit i'm gonna
cheat slightly
in this next section because i'm going
to draw a perfect circle here
but you know what i would suggest is if
you don't carry a pair of compasses
around with you into exams the thing
that i always used to do was i would
carry a roll of tape
into my exam not to stick anything
together but it allowed me to just place
it down on the um on the page and just
draw a really quick circle um it didn't
mean all of my circles were the same
size but you know what it worked for me
um so it was quick and dirty and it
worked okay
so there you go there's our boundary
right and i might as well just mark that
in that's
x plus 2 all squared plus y squared is
equal to 4 there's our boundary i've
dotted it to indicate that it's actually
not included in my inequality i go all
the way over to negative 4 because from
the center which we said was negative 2
i've got that radius of 2 and i touch at
the origin that means how far am i going
up answer and that's 2i up there and
negative 2i down here uh and then what
else do i need we'll actually need to
shade that subset that inside part gets
all of those smaller circles right so
again sorry teeny bit of cheating here
but there you go let's see let's pop
that in there
and uh get this looking about right so
get the color right
phil's already been chosen and now let's
make this the appropriate size
okay there you go of course you just
grab your pencil and shade like so but
hopefully this is nice and clear for you
okay now in terms of what we were
looking for when we were marking this i
think if you look go back to the paper
there were three marks on this there you
go part a three marks over there on the
right hand side i'm looking for things
like number one did you get the boundary
right like was it a circle and is that
circle in the correct place um things
like these um these sort of boundary
values here are really important to mark
in you you've absolutely got to put the
center of the circle on there that's
kind of an essential and non-negotiable
did you get that it was dotted that was
also important and then the shape of it
had to be reasonably accurate and the
fact it was shaded on the inside and not
the outside so these are all of the
features that we were looking for